The earth has an elegant cycle of life.
It’s the story of carbon.
And over billions of years, it has evolved
to look something like this.
And it starts with a plant.
Plants and microorganisms absorb carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere.
Then they use energy from the sun to convert
that carbon into oxygen…
And sugar, which they use to grow.
And as they grow, they emit some carbon back
into the atmosphere.
But all plants eventually die.
And some are consumed by bacteria — others
by larger beasts.
These animals eat plants for energy.
And they breathe out carbon.
But eventually, those animals die, too.
And they end up in the ground.
Meanwhile, a similar thing happens in the
ocean.
Coral and plankton need carbon from the water
to survive.
Luckily, the ocean has carbon because it absorbs
some from the atmosphere.
And, when rain falls to the earth, it grabs
some carbon from the atmosphere...
... and from rocks...
… and flows into the ocean, where the coral
and plankton use carbon to grow.
Or other animals use it to grow.
But just like animals, the coral and plankton die, too.
In short, all living things are made of carbon
— and they eventually end up in the ground.
Some of that carbon will eventually get back
to the atmosphere.
But some of it normally stays in the ground.
Usually, dead things decay and turn into rocks.
Eventually, they’re crushed — and extreme
heat and pressure causes them to melt…
and emit the carbon, which is trapped
underground.
Over time, that trapped carbon eventually
escapes into the atmosphere — when volcanoes
erupt.
And the cycle starts again.
But occasionally, dead plants and animals
don't turn into rock.
They don't decay fast enough, so they turn into
oil, coal, or natural gas…
This carbon gets stuck in the ground.
This is the elegant system that keeps carbon
cycling through Earth at a steady pace.
Carbon in the atmosphere keeps some heat from
leaving Earth.
It keeps Earth at a stable temperature.
But very recently, one of these animals started
to dig up the carbon in the ground.
They took the carbon that was stuck in the
ground and put it back into the atmosphere.
And they did this so much — in such a short
time span — that this cycle was disrupted.
Too much carbon was being put into the atmosphere.
Heat that would normally be able to escape
bounced back and stayed on Earth.
And Earth started to get warmer and warmer.
Really recently, just a few months ago,
more than 100 bipedal scientists said they
might only have 12 years to stop a disastrous
amount of warming.
So these animals need to not only stop putting
carbon in the atmosphere, but also get carbon
out of the atmosphere.
They found that one way to remove carbon is
to grow more plants.
They could stop cutting down trees.
Or raise livestock in ways that help restore
grass.
Another way is to let plants suck up carbon
from the atmosphere —
— but then burn them for energy.
And then trapping the carbon they emit underground.
They could also build machines to suck air
from the atmosphere and filter out the carbon.
But they haven't figured out how to do this
fast enough.
There are many ways these animals can tweak
this cycle to suck carbon out of the atmosphere.
A combination of them is probably the best
way forward.
But, first, these animals need to figure out
how to stop putting it there in the first place.
If you haven't heard already, we've launched a paid membership program
on YouTube called the Vox Video Lab.
For a small payment, you have access to some amazing perks,
like access to livestreams with our creators and a little badge that appears
next to your name and it'll upgrade over time.
This is the best way to support our channel.
It'll help us do more ambitious journalism, so we can bring better content to you guys.
If you want to learn more, just head to vox.com/join.